je pense que les républicains ont besoin
d'un président si d'autres souhaité
l'être ou contester la ligne de laurent
wauquiez
il fallait qu'il soit candidat ne l'ont
pas été donc je crois qu'il faut que les
républicains demeurent et perdure on a
besoin d'une grande force
d'interposition au fond entre le
gouvernement monsieur macron et les
extrêmes
monsieur macron adore parler avec les
extrêmes avec l'extrême gauche et
l'extrême droite c'est une manière pour
lui de n'exister tout seul on a besoin
dans le champ républicain dans le champ
le vrai champ de la démocratie on a
besoin d'une opposition est en tout cas
d'une force d'alternance si aucune
alternance possible monsieur courant et
qu'il échoue je le souhaite pas moi je
souhaite que la france hélas réussissent
mais s'il échoue il ya toujours dans un
pays une alternance possible et
aujourd'hui les républicains sont en
convalescence après cette année terrible
qui a été un pur
pour nous 2010 est donc nous avons
besoin de représenter cette force
d'alternance et on a pas besoin
immédiatement d'avoir des oppositions au
sein même de notre propre formation aux
besoins la reconstruire donc il faut la
reconstruire
et puis si ça se passe pas bien là bas
on verra on en fera le bilan
mais moi je prends le pari que ça va
bien se passer est qu'on va redevenir
une force d'alternance qui n'est pas le
cas aujourd'hui totalement
et quand j'entends bien ce que vous
dites mais je me permets d'insister
parce que c'est vrai pendant beaucoup de
critiques contre monsieur wauquiez alors
gérald darmanin voulait me dire gérald
darmanin il est du ministre il est
devenu ministre de monsieur macron et
puis maintenant même il fait partie du
parti il apprend qu'il est disqualifié
enfin lui aussi dit qu'avec ma avec
wauquiez c'est quand même l'extréme
nation de la droite qui se prépare on
entendre quand même beaucoup ça même
dans votre parti alors à votre avis
pourquoi est ce que monsieur wauquiez
suscite autant de blancs sur les gets
immédiates laurent wauquiez il a une
aînée
gillet aussi clivant il dit noir blanc
et les qui vend donc certains peuvent ne
pas se reconnaître dans ça et pour
rassembler c'est pas évident des clients
non mais pour faire ça semblait tomber
pour faire exister l'opposition c'est
peut-être nécessaire c'est peut-être
nécessaire est-ce qu'ils ne gagnent pas
aujourd'hui toujours son ambiguïté au
soir du premier tome non il y avait
dedans je crois pas et je crois que
c'est un mauvais procès qui a été fait
alors évoqué à deauville se poursuit ce
port se sauver par exemple quelqu'un qui
a été exclu de votre parti c'est franck
riester qui dit encore ce matin on se
dirige tout droit vers une alliance en
tous les cas d'idées avec le front
national vous vous dites vous voulez
incarné l'opposition dans le champ
républicain je pense ça pour une insulte
voilà je vais n'a su que je pense qu'on
n'a pas le droit de dire ça d'abord ils
ont été membre d'un républicain pendant
longtemps ils ont demandé l'investiture
des républicains pendant longtemps ils
ont sauté dans les organes directeurs
des républicains à l'époque on faisait
le mini voilà ça a été pour un certain
nombre la ligne de position pendant
l'élection
le deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle n'a pas été la mienne moi
j'ai voté manuel maquereau au deuxième
tour donc je me sens absolument libre
pour dire que ceux qui ont fait un autre
choix que vous font de ne pas aller
voter
c'était un choix qu'ils ont exercé en
toute liberté et qui doivent pas le
porter en tout cas comme une commune
crois et je pense que ceux qui sont
rentrés au gouvernement il avait besoin
d'un certain nombre d'alibi ou prétexte
pour entrer au gouvernement que c'était
un prétexte assez facile me semble-t-il